كاس العالم للشباب تحت 20 عاما خارج حدودي
اندونيسيا هكذا قرر الفيفا وهكذا اتخذ
القرار كل هذا جاع عقم اجتماع دمر رئيس
الفيفا جاني انفنتينو ورئيس الاتحاد
الاندونيسي لكره القدم اريد طاهر وهو وزير
ايضا في حكومه الرئيس جوكو ويدودو الالغاء
ياتي بعد ان رفض شاشه اندونيسيون وفي
مقدمتهم حاكمه اقليمي جزيره بالي وجا
والوسطى اضافه الى احزاب حاكمه ومعارضه
على حد سواء حضور المنتخب الاسرائيلي في
اقاليمهم الرئيس الاندونيسي من جهته كان
قد اكد في بيان له قبل يومين ان بلاده
ستظل ثابته على موقفها الداعم للشعب
الفلسطيني واستقلاله ومناهضه الاحتلال رغم
استضافه البطوله لانها تتبع لوائح وانظمه
الفيفا وهي التي تشرف على داعيا الى الفصل
بين الرياضه والسياسه لكن دون جدوى سلام
جاء منك اضمن لكم ان مشاركه اسرائيل لن
تؤثر على موقفنا وسياساتنا الخارجيه تجاه
فلسطين لان دعمنا لفلسطين كان دائما قويا
وثابتا وفيما يتعلق بكاس العالم تحت 20
عاما نتفق مع تصريح السفير الفلسطيني في
اندونيسيا بان الفيفا لديها قواعد يجب على
اعضائها الالتزام بها لذا يجب الا نخلط
بين الرياضه والمسائل السياسيه
الحكومه الاندونيسيه ممثله بوزير الرياضه
مهاجر افندي ورئيس الاتحاد اريك طاهر سعد
جاهده الى عدم الغاء الاستضافه لكن رفض
شاشه محليين في الاقليم والمحافظات دخول
الفريق الاسرائيلي الى مناطقهم اجزم
الموقف السياسي الوطني تجاه الامر
بالاضافه الى رفض عدد من منظمات المجتمع
المدني والمنظمات الدينيه الكبرى في
البلاد الفيفا في بيانه قال ان دوله مضيفه
اخرى سيتم الاعلان عنها لاستضافه
المونديال الشبابي مع الابقاء على
المواعيد المحدده سابقا لكنه لم ينسى ان
يلمح الاحتمال فرض عقوبات على الاتحاد
الاندونيسي لكره القدم